discipline is your best friend it will
take care of you like nothing else can
do not take the easy way out do not give
up based on instinct take the step step
aggressively toward your fear he's an
American podcaster author and retired
United States Navy SEAL
he received the Silver Star and the
Bronze Star for his actions in the Iraq
war he started a weekly podcast covering
topics like leadership exercise and
lessons from a former Navy SEAL
he's jockle willing and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success rule
number six is my personal favorite and I
love to know which one you guys like the
best also guys if you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you
please leave it down in the comments
below put quotes around it to other
people can be inspired by your sharing
and also when you write it down you're
much more likely to lock it in for
yourself to enjoy
one of my direct subordinates one of my
guys that work for me he would he would
call me up or pull me aside with some
major problems on the issue that was
going on and he'd say possibly got this
and that and the other thing and I look
at him and I'd say good and finally one
day he was telling me about some issue
that he was having some problem and he
said I already know what you're gonna
say I said well what am I gonna say he
said you're gonna say good he said
that's what you always say when
something is wrong in going bad you
always just look at me and say good and
I said well yeah when things are going
bad
there's going to be some good that's
going to come from it didn't get the new
high speed gear we want it good didn't
get promoted
time you get better omission got careful
good reading focus on the other one
didn't get funded didn't get the job you
wanted got injured sprained my ankle got
capped out good got B
[Music]
unexpected problems good
we have the opportunity to figure out a
solution that's it when things are going
bad don't get all bummed out don't get
startled don't get frustrated
if you can say the word good guess
means you're still alive that means
you're still believing and if you're
still breathing
oh now you still got some fight left in
you so get up dust off reload
recalibrate re-engage go out on the
attack I always say that discipline is
the root of all good qualities but you
have to absolutely apply it to things
outside of just waking up early it's
it's everything it's working out every
day making yourself stronger and faster
and more flexible and healthier
discipline is eating right foods to fuel
your system it
it's about disciplining your emotions so
you can make good decisions it's about
having the discipline to control your
ego so your ego doesn't get out of hand
and control you it's about treating
people the way you would want to be
treated and doing the tasks that you
don't necessarily want to do but that
you know will help you or help your team
so facing your fears keep discipline to
face your fears so you can conquer them
and that's what discipline is discipline
means taking the hard road the uphill
road to do what's right for yourself and
for other people
it's so often the e-zpass the e-zpass it
calls to us to be weak for that moment
to break down for that moment to give in
to the desire and the short-term
gratification but the discipline will
not allow that
the discipline calls for strength and
fortitude and will it won't accept
weakness it won't tolerate another
breakdown a discipline can seem like
it's your worst enemy but the reality is
discipline is your best friend it will
take care of you like nothing else can
then we'll put you on that path the path
to strength and health and intelligence
and happiness and most importantly it'll
put you on that path to freedom people
want to know how to stop the laziness
and they will know how to stop the
procrastination and you know they have
some idea in their head you know some
kind of a vision what they want to do
but they don't know where to start in
order start it you know they don't know
where to start and say they say hey
where do I start
and and when's the best time to start
and I have a very simple answer for that
here and now
that's it you want to improve you want
to get better you want to get on a
workout program or a clean diet you want
to start a business you want to write a
book or make a movie or build a house or
a computer or put together some mobile
application where do you start you start
right here and when do you start you
start right now you initiate the action
aggressively you go because the idea
isn't going to execute itself and the
book isn't going to write itself and the
weights out in the gym they're not going
to move themselves you have to do it and
you have to do it now and that means you
got to stop thinking about it and stop
dreaming about it and stop researching
every aspect of it and reading all about
it and debating the pros and cons of it
just start doing it take that first step
and make it happen
get after it and get after it here and
now a person's strengths are often their
biggest weaknesses and so that also
means that their weaknesses can be their
strengths so me I am weak in all those
ways that I listed I am weak but I don't
accept that I don't accept that I am
what I am and that that is what I'm
doing to be no I don't accept that
I'm fighting I'm always fighting I'm
struggling and I'm strapping and kicking
and calling it those weaknesses
to change them stop them
somedays I win some days I don't but
each and every day I get back up and I
move forward with my fists clenched
toward the battle torn to struggle and I
fight with everything I've got to
overcome those weaknesses and those
shortfalls and those flaws as I strive
to be just a little bit better today
than I was yesterday first of all before
the war I then military sent me to
college so I had to go to college and I
as I said earlier as I said before I was
super focused when I went to college
I've been in the SEAL Teams for ten
years I was a go-getter I was a hard
charger I was like oh you want me to
read this book boom I would sit down and
just force myself to read it and then
got back to the SEAL Teams and like like
when I was a college I literally read
every single thing that I was assigned
and nobody does that in college nobody
does that
I read every single page of every single
thing I was assigned during college
that's ridiculous it's almost a waste of
time it's almost embarrassing EKKO
definitely thinks it's a waste of time
but but it was because I just could just
go lock my brain around and get it done
yeah then get back to the teams and the
teams officer the teams you have a lot
of administrative play were to do
evaluations and after-action reports on
all these things and I would do the same
thing I just go on a lockdown mode and I
put my brain on it and boom I'd go
through it and just get it done I would
just be able to focus so they each thing
laser focus laser focus that report done
God never give me a gun report done
there's another kind of instinct that
you need to be on the lookout for and
this one is a liar this one is a
saboteur well this one is a back biter
and like the devil himself he's a
shapeshifter
he's gonna disguise himself and make you
think he's got your best interest in
mind but he doesn't this is the instinct
that says you've had enough this is the
instinct that says you've given it your
best shot you can you can stand down you
can back off you can take a knee this is
the instinct it says you can rest now do
not listen to that instinct do not
listen that instinct is a liar and wants
to bring you down that that's the
instinct that's a defense mechanism you
want to give you an out place to run to
a little a little place of sympathy an
amnesty a little place of amnesty where
everything is forgiven where all these
these failures can gather together and
comfort and drown their sorrows in lies
and in deception and they tell each
other and they'll tell me you you did
the best you could know they'll say the
deck the deck the deck was stacked
against you and they'll say it's not
your fault and they'll tell you it's
okay to stop it's okay to settle it's
okay to give up
and that is the instinct you need to
fight you need to push back to smash
into the ground do not take the easy way
out do not give up based on instinct if
you are forced to stand down
to retreat so that you can rebuild
Andrea tack so be it but make that
decision based on logic not on the
instinct of surrender and defeat and you
need to train that instinct your
instinct train it to say get up go fight
on and if that is what you become if
that becomes your fundamental reaction
to adversity if that becomes your gut
instinct then you will overcome just
about anything that stands in your path
there's been thousands and hundreds and
thousands and millions of warriors that
have been in very stressful situations
faced evil and faced death much worse
than the situation I'm in or you're in
that we might consider stressful and I
even did this when I was overseas when I
was on deployment when I was a combat
leader I was feeling stressed and you
know what we took casualty and it was
awful and it was heartbreaking and
but there were other soldiers and
warriors throughout time that have been
in much worse situations Gettysburg or
Vicksburg or the Battle of the Bulge and
in all those horrible situations they
proved really that humans can withstand
almost most unimaginable stress which
meant to me that I could to and you can
and the first step for me is doing that
taking that look to gain some
perspective and then in order to gain
perspective you got to do something that
we already talked about you've got to
detach you've got to detach from the
problems or the stress that you're
experiencing so that you can get that
perspective of them now there's a couple
different types of stress now if it's
something that you can control that's
causing you stress well why aren't you
getting control of it now there's also
stress that's caused by things that you
cannot control and if you remember
talking earlier about artillery and how
horrible that was or what made it so
horrible was that there's no control
over so if you can't control something
and you can't get control of it you have
to at least embrace what you can and I'm
not saying you're going to embrace
artillery shelling but I'll tell you
what when it comes to things like
artillery or for us in Ramadi was IEDs
and we could do everything we could do
to mitigate that risk but eventually
there's only so much you can do and you
cannot completely eliminate it
but you can't control it so why you
going to worry about it why are you
going to stress about it if there's
something that's completely beyond your
control
you cannot you've got to detach from it
and not let yourself get stressed about
it and on top of that if it's something
that you can't control how can you look
at it in a different light how can you
see it in a way that you could actually
take advantage of it how can you take
that stress and make it into some kind
of a lie you know the the chaos of
combat is something that I couldn't
control but I had to embrace it so I
could try and figure out how to take
advantage of it so when it comes to
stress don't fight it
turn it on itself and use it use it use
it to make yourself sharper and more
alert and use it to make yourself sink
more and learn more and get better and
use that stress as a catalyst to make
yourself better your book isn't i mean
it's thick but I should have been able
to read this in two or three solid days
I've read yes I told you how successful
I was yes not very at bugs they should
Adam and it's a it's a it's a it's a
fail it's a you know what though I think
this is a failure on my part I I think
that this is the same thing we were
talking about on the last podcast and I
think echo said would you say all you
know what I'm not going to finish this
book right now it's it I don't really
want to it's sort of like when you say
oh I'm not going to oil it's not nothing
I want to though that's what I'm saying
you say but I don't want to do it right
now I can push it off a little bit you
accept that do you accept that answer
you accept that answer
the soldier
od rent wouldn't accept that answer
would not do you self talk not really
not really I'm not a guy that says you
know I'm going to do this I'm going to
do that I just do it right I just go and
do whatever that thing is you know I
actually took this question from Twitter
and I answered the question in one word
you've lived a life dominated by doubt
and fear how do you step into bravery
step that's how you step into bravery
step take the step step aggressively
towards your fear and that that's a step
towards your fear is the step in the
bravery because we're scared of what we
don't know and there is only one way to
learn and to know and that is to
confront that fear you have to step you
have to go and this simple action this
simple attitude it answers so many
questions
my theory here would be if you're afraid
of fighting and altercations go change
it so if you're afraid of heights work
on some rock climbing climbing if you're
afraid of the water time to swim it's
time to surf it's time to get out there
if you're afraid of pull-ups if you're
afraid of pulse duple if you're in
squats do squats if you're afraid of
public speaking go speak in public
mm-hmm if you're afraid to start a
business start a business make it small
and on all these what you have to do is
you have to mitigate the risk and you
have to ease yourself into it but you
got to go for it and eventually you will
overcome that fear
but the hard part is you got to take
that first step you've got to take that
first step to begin to inoculate
yourself against the fear against the
fear of the thing that's in your mind
because that fear generally is in your
mind yeah you know when you get up on
stage to a public speaking people are
not going to throw tomatoes at you and
say oh my you're an idiot get off the
stage now right 30 they're gonna sit
there you know so there's nothing to
fear
yeah it's in it's in your head people
watching your small matter of the Lord
yeah I tweeted a joke and I asked them
if you'd like to take part in a fitness
challenge he graciously came with a
counteroffer instead how about a graphic
match for some reason I said yes and so
here I am now it's saying indigo
and
yes
and actually have to get choked out
[Applause]
decisive victories ha really no really
honestly it's just cuz I've been
training for a long time and I have that
skill set you know it's something that
anybody could get is not because I'm
special it's just cuz I trained for a
long time doing this and if the roles
were reversed and he's been training
over than me you'll be doing that right
there to me that's the way it works even
if I look like this and he was like that
yeah I'm more than happy to get
135-pound right here right now that will
show me what it's about yells are you
worse than I just did you hear yes if
you want that job I got guys standing by
they're hungry I've had enough of Jocko
for one day all yes
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because Michelangelo Reiko asking to
till there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know what a Jacko's say
that had the biggest impact on you
what cliff did you enjoy the most and
what immediate action are you going to
take in your life or your business after
watching this clips
leave it down in the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion
finally I want to give a quick chart it
says a No thank yous a knows too much
you're picking up a copy of my book your
one word and posting that picture online
I really appreciate it also they know
thank you so much for all the love
you've given to the believe nation
community for being a part of almost all
of our live chats and just being a force
within the comments I really really
really appreciate your support so thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
nobody likes being evaluated right
nobody hmm now you might get somebody
that says oh I love being coach cinch
and there are some people that are
pretty positive about that and as a
matter of fact I have clients where they
want to be coached right but most people
especially in a normal environment like
if you go out new hire someone to coach
you okay but most people in a normal
environment they don't like being
evaluated they don't like being judged
yeah always judging so the first thing
you have to do when it comes to being
evaluated is get that in your head that
you like everybody else has defense
mechanisms and they're going to flare up
as soon as somebody says something
critical of you as soon as somebody goes
to evaluate you your defense mechanisms
are going to go up and then once that
happens once you feel those defense
mechanisms go up you got to put your ego
in check mm-hmm you got to put your ego
in check and then once you do that you
got to listen listen I know it sounds
crazy listen to what they're saying
don't even don't even think of a
response to yourself you know what I'm
not even going to respond I'm only going
to listen to what they're saying yeah
but in in to kind of an you're already
you can't even take it no no I can take
it oh I'm saying but I think because
people will quote-unquote do that but
they won't really do it as far as just
I'm not going to say anything I'm just
going to list it yeah there but that's
actually like that's actually like a
that's actually how they set it up to
look I'm not even saying I'm just going
to listen yeah exactly what I'm talking
about it you know all body language you
can attain where they're like you know
they'll do that kind of just don't do
that hold on to that so to you right you
got to listen and not just listen but
truly listen not listen just with your
ears but listen with your mind and your
brain and with an open mind an open mind
and then think about what people are
saying and then see it is important to
see it from their perspective because if
you just see it from your perspective
you're not even seeing
what the criticism really is you're only
seeing the defense of the criticism so
actually get in their mind and say wow
what does this look like from their
perspective why would they be taking the
effort and the risk and the challenge of
trying to present this problem to me if
it wasn't important mm-hmm are they just
doing it just to make me mad no they're
trying to help you and you know what
just like just like a joke and they say
like every joke has some little truth to
it every little criticism even if the
person is your archrival their criticism
is built on something so what is that
reality that you can take away from it
even you got to take it with a grain of
salt especially if the person like it
says here if the person has different
opinions and mode as well of course they
have different opinions you want people
with different opinions maybe they have
different motives so maybe you think
they're trying to usurp your authority
or something like that so you maybe you
got to take it with a grain of salt but
find the grain of truth in there too and
find what it is from their perspective
what the problem is and learn from it
and one of the most beautiful things
about this is you take the criticism and
you make adjustments you know how do I
deal with about being evaluated I try
and accept the evaluation and make
adjustments to improve myself as a human
mm-hmm that's how I deal with being
evaluated and I'm not saying I deal with
it anybody better than anybody else
because everybody gets defensive
myself included hmm you know we had a
little conversation when we started
tonight right sir you said I repeated
some stuff on the last podcast allegedly
and you know and then we talked through
it and then I said you know and you know
I noticed that your camera work was a
little bit off and you know we just put
my point was just to prove how defensive
we all get and we all get and you know
what I did I said you know what I
noticed that too you know as far as me
repeating there was a couple of
sections and it was because we poor I
pulled from multiple different books and
they had a little bit of overlap yeah
and looking back on it probably
shouldn't have but at that time I
thought you know what this is
emphasizing really important points yeah
but still people want to hear the same
thing over and over again so I probably
should have done that so guess what
criticism accepted I will adapt adjust
and I will make improvements to my game
based on your criticism of my technique
my skill and my life there's so much
knowledge out there so much information
so many ways to get better and we make
we make so many mistakes whether were
the product of our mistakes and
oftentimes the lesson is sitting there
right in front of our face it's there to
be learned but we miss it or we don't
pay attention to it or we think we know
better
until it punches us in the face and the
most important thing to learn is that we
have so much to learn we all do and we
can learn from school and from people
and from experience and we learn from
life but you have to process the
information you have to absorb it you
have to accept it you have to open your
mind you've got to free your mind so
that you can learn and make real
progress and as far as
regrets some things I wish I would have
done differently of course hindsight
hindsight is twenty-twenty and looking
back of course who wouldn't want to take
another go at something and improve on
the first try by doing it again and then
why not do it again and again and again
and why not just do it over and over
again until you have it perfect but the
fact is you don't get that chance you
get one shot one shot at this gig right
here life one life and that's all you've
gotten and regret in and of itself it's
worthless it does nothing for you
in fact the only valuable thing in
regret is the lesson you learned the
knowledge that you gained but walking
around filled with regret it gets you
nothing
so learn and move on
don't let regret beat you down don't be
a slave to regret no let it teach you
let it make you better let the fear of
regret fuel you to take action today now
to take action now to become a better
person
not filled with regret but filled with
knowledge
filled with knowledge and strength and
power and filled with life with the man
in the cave and this idea and the spot
of the enemy and and that was a thought
that used to drive me and can haunt me
and make me get up early and work hard
to push myself because I knew that
somewhere out there there was an enemy a
real enemy a real man a person a human
[Music]
that was waiting and that was preparing
for me and therefore I needed to prepare
for him I needed to be ready I needed to
be the things I always talked about I
needed to be stronger and faster and
smarter and better so that when we did
meet on the battlefield I would be
ready for that rendezvous for that
meeting that's fate that battle and that
thought that thought of the enemy yes it
absolutely fueled me it and when I was a
leader in the SEAL Teams in charge of
men it was even more profound because I
was thinking about that rendezvous for
everybody that I led everyone I was in
charge of everyone that I trained and I
felt that burden the burden of
responsibility to prepare those men and
protect those those men knows those
frogmen those Warriors my brothers
and it it was my burden to train those
guys and prepared them it and that
burden it may have made me a little bit
crazy a little bit paranoid little bit
over the top
[Music]
but
I didn't really know any any other way
[Music]
and
so now I am no longer
a combat
I no longer prepare men for war
so the drive and the motivation is from
a different place
[Music]
from a solemn place
the drive now and the motivation now is
not really fully animal
now it's from my friends not brothers
it's from
those seals that I knew
[Music]
and that I
cared about more than anything and that
they sacrificed everything
for us for me those guys they gave their
lives for us
they in their own
I cannot help but stink and remember
that every breath that we take is a
gift it's a sacred
from those men every day we have every
sunrise every thought and every smile of
every last
[Music]
and I will treasure
if the whole life
and I will not let it go to waste now
one second
you know cherish every moment of it and
I will live it
I will live it in their memory
[Music]
in your honor
[Music]